[Music]
ryan reynolds gal gadot and dwayne the
rock johnson that's a lot of star power
but who ends up on top at the end of
netflix's red notice let's dive in
dwayne the rock johnson gets top billing
in the action comedy which sees his
character special agent john hartley
tasked with working with one of the most
notorious art thieves in the world nolan
booth played by ryan reynolds they have
to work together in order to prevent the
theft of three major historical
artifacts by the bishop another art
thief played by gal gadot at the
beginning of red notice special agent
hartley is introduced as an fbi profiler
chasing after nolan booth after hunting
down booth in bali hartley seems shocked
when he finds his life completely turned
upside down by the bishop framed for the
theft of cleopatra's first egg harley is
imprisoned in russia where he shares a
cell with booth in prison hartley and
booth bond over the shared trauma from
their poor relationships with their
fathers hartley is subsequently forced
to team up with booths supposedly to
restore the former fbi agent's good name
and prevent the bishop from getting all
three eggs which are worth 300 million
dollars as a set their shared adventure
first begins with a daring escape from
prison but eventually leads them all the
way from rome to south america
that's fun
this is my best friend
we're not friends
we're best friends
while the two repeatedly tell each other
how much they hate one another it
becomes very clear that the experience
has produced a genuine friendship
between them eventually however the
entire ordeal is revealed to be a ruse
designed by hartley and the bishop who
are actually lovers well the final twist
of the film might come as a surprise to
some viewers small hints at hartley's
deception are scattered throughout the
film from his unnecessary flirtatious
dance with the bishop to his sudden
ability to escape from previously
unbreakable handcuffs
during their adventure booth reveals
that his father was obsessed with
locating the hidden treasure of hitler's
secret arts and antiquities dealer
unfortunately for some unknown reason
booth's father came to believe that his
son was responsible for the temporary
loss of a prized nazi watch as a result
as he reveals to hartley in prison his
father did not speak to him for more
than a year and their strange
relationship led to booth embracing a
lonely life of crime however throughout
the film booth and hartley become close
after the two escaped the reach of the
police in south america booth is
actually willing to sacrifice the third
egg in order to save his new friend
after hartley and the bishop's betrayal
is revealed though booth quickly sells
them out to interpol freezing their 300
million dollar payout
see
now we're even
if everyone loses no one gets the money
we can all be friends again
booth then takes his new best friends on
a mission to the louvre in paris which
he promises will offer double the payout
and triple the challenge honestly it all
seems like a lot to take on for someone
who just wants to make a few friends
while nolan booth and john hartley both
end up being decidedly different people
than they initially seem to be gal
gadetz the bishop is pretty much exactly
the character she says that she is at
the beginning of red notice she loves to
steal from people and takes joy and
beating booth at every turn while the
film doesn't explore the bishop's
origins nearly as much as it does booths
and hartleys she does share a few
important pieces of information that
make it clear why she turned to a life
of crime in the middle of the film the
bishop holds an intelligence analyst
hostage and treats him as a largely
unwilling therapist during their session
she explains that she also faced a tough
childhood and that her father made her
who she is today she further questions
whether her inability to accept second
place is what keeps her from being truly
happy and admits that she struggles to
trust people however the events of the
film seem to lead to her discovering a
new found faith in her fellow human
beings when presented with the
opportunity to form a three-person team
with her lover slash art thieving
partner and her former rival she is the
first to accept in fact while hartley is
initially reluctant to form a new team
it's gadot's bishop who persuades him
into agreeing
interpol inspector irvashi das played by
ritu arya perhaps the only truly
honorable character in red notice spends
the entirety of the film just trying to
keep up she quickly deduces that special
agent john hartley is not who he claims
to be and chases the film's art thieving
trio all over the world after the bishop
and hartley revealed the location of all
three of cleopatra's eggs daz leads a
team of police to recover them crashing
the wedding of an egyptian billionaire's
daughter and arresting performer ed
sheeran in the process while daz is
ultimately unable to keep the bishop
hartley or nolan booth in prison for a
substantial period of time one has to
hope that putting ed sheeran behind bars
serves as some sort of consolation prize
right
you know who i am
i was in game of thrones
does is last seen in red notice sending
out three red notices in the hopes of
catching the infamous art thieves at the
center of the movie neatly setting up a
sequel
cleopatra's eggs serve as the macguffin
of red notice
how we're gonna find this egg i don't
know look for a box that says mcguffin
the hunt for cleopatra's eggs is put
into motion at the beginning of the film
after an egyptian billionaire offers a
300 million dollar prize in exchange for
having them delivered to the wedding of
his daughter also named cleopatra the
eggs are scattered across the globe the
first place they wound up is in a museum
in rome the second is in a private
estate and the third is in a long
forgotten south american bunker filled
with nazi memorabilia while it's not
explicitly said what happens to the eggs
after inspector daws recovers them in
egypt it's safe to assume that they
found their way to a museum of some kind
hopefully it's a location where they'll
be better protected than they were in
their prior homes while the eggs
certainly sound like legitimate
artifacts they are completely fictional
in an interview with the rap red notice
producer hiram garcia even recounted his
amusement at director ross and marshall
thurber's ability to fool people with
such a believable fictional history for
the objects garcia revealed at the end
of the pitch the same thing always came
up which was i had no idea about the
whole cleopatra thing and with great
comedic timing he always said oh i just
made all that up it has such a
well-conceived backstory that you wish
they were real but no they were totally
made up it's a very fun idea he had come
up with
taking that into account one can only
imagine what other fictional treasures
might exist in the world of red notice
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite new movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one